when you tell people that i run a slot
car
they go what what's that
i never heard of that before
when they first do it they go wow
this is fun
[Music]
i am buzz frank perry i am the
proprietor of buzzerama the slot car
racing center of the world
[Music]
racing is a hobby sport that's
participated in all over the world
in 1965 it was my hobby i was one of the
first to open in new york
there was 48 places like this in the
city
today i'm in
i'm the lone survivor
they have 12 volt dc motors in them and
a guide flag that fits in the slot and
when you hit the hand controller it
energizes those lanes
and gives the motor juice
the fastest cars can go upwards of 100
miles an hour so they're like blurs now
you have to hear them yo
you can hardly see them you have to
listen to them you go
wow
kids play with computer now
and there's no interaction with anyone
over here they have an interaction
with other drivers they compete they
congratulate each other you learn
sportsmanship
it's really great
just watching the cars go around the
tracks pumps up your adrenaline and you
get all excited and that that thrill
never leaves you
you always think about it
[Music]
[Music]
the most unique part of rally car racing
is if a regular person were to hear the
in-car audio of a driver and a co-driver
it would seem like they were speaking
gibberish
in actuality it's a language that tells
that driver what is coming next
they really are just the eyes for the
driver before they can get to that spot
[Music]
rally car racing in america is stage
racing
you can have anywhere from 12 to 14
stages
anywhere from six to
20 miles in some cases i mean you're
racing other competitors but really it's
you against the clock
[Music]
so inside of a rally car we have two
people we have a driver and a co-driver
the driver drives the car tries to keep
it on the road without wrecking it
and the co-driver is responsible for
reading the notes
50 turn a left three will tighten right
three minus no cut
so for this example we have 50 here so
that means before the next
note i call you'll have 50 meters
and then t for me stands for turn which
means you'll change roads from the road
that you're currently on and then a left
three left obviously means your corner
is going to go to the left and a three
is the degree of the corner
there's so much information
to take in from the co-driver you say
120 miles over a weekend there could be
as many as two to three thousand
different commands that co-driver is
reading the driver
pretty much that co-driver you know
isn't the computer of that car he or she
is gonna get you from point a to point b
and as a driver you need to trust what
that co-driver is telling you
we started
as a team when i was 15
and
sometimes i feel like i can simply read
his mind
i really trust what she is telling me
to the point where if i had to close my
eyes and maybe not drive at race speed
she could tell me pace notes
and i could still drive blind
into left three
into right four up
king seventy
right four long up tightens that t to a
right two break turn left three off
camber forty
into a care left three down fifty
turn left three tightens into a right
three minus
rallies let me see how uh you know one
of my children has grown up and how
they've become if i looked at her as a
co-driver and not a not a daughter or a
relative i'd grab her in a heartbeat
i'd love to make it a full-time career
one day and and rally internationally
and i'd love to just follow in my dad's
footsteps
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
when you roll up to that line you are
getting butterflies in your stomach
you're nervous you're sweating but once
you get the bug you get hooked and then
it's all over
[Music]
we're celebrating our 23rd year of the
top cop program here at sonoma raceway
top the cops is a program where high
school students can come out to the
racetrack on a wednesday night
race their car
against a uniformed policeman in a stock
police car
i'm kevin mckinney the program director
for the top the cops program i'm a
retired law enforcement officer from
santa rosa police department we've been
doing this from april through august for
the past 23 seasons
there was illegal street racing being
done in and around the city of santa
rosa
and i thought
we need to get these people over here to
the racetrack so they stop doing that
out on the street
if you want to race
fine come on out here and race don't do
it out on the street
[Music]
these are our future these kids here
i pull up next to a cop at the start
line i always just think oh it'd be
great if i beat them it's a great
feeling when you pass them on the drag
ship going 100 miles an hour
there is a very competitive spirit to it
but you know it's all about the kids
there's a lot of negativity in the world
today a lot of negativity towards law
enforcement
what we try to do out here
is make something good something
positive out of this program something
that is worthwhile
nowhere in the country is this being
done on a regular basis the top the cops
program did help curb illegal street
racing it's been a great positive
program all these years
[Music]
there's sun there's sand
there's speed
well hold on i'm getting ahead of myself
in 1947 a hundred miles east of la a
bunch of world war ii vets formed a car
club called the oilers taking their
model t fords hot rodding them up and
racing them in the mojave desert
eventually the men got old the cars
broke down and their brand of bare
knuckle drag racing all but stopped
until now
[Music]
my name is mel stiltz i'm with the race
of gentlemen my name is bobby green i'm
with the race of gentlemen
with the blessing of the oilers club
founders mel and bobby resurrected the
club
rebranding it the race of gentlemen
what is the race of gentlemen it's a
vintage car race on the beach but
there's that other layer to it the race
of gentlemen is in a sense a time travel
event
we go to great lengths to make it feel
like you could be in a different time
era
and the rules of the race stay true to
the time period as well
the body engine and running gear must be
of a certain age and must be
american-made
well there's definitely something about
america in cars
all those incredible cars that we
created
starting from let's say the 1910s
up until probably about the 60s we're so
different than anywhere else in the
world things today are made to last a
month the 1932
ford is made to last forever
it's not just about the cars and the
bikes it's about the camaraderie and all
the things that go in
people are like oh this is so cool
because not only is it a race it's like
a scene it's like a set it's lost in
time
and for the race of gentlemen the love
of classic american cars transcends
generations you've got young kids that
want to have a more simple life and
build and make things and then you've
got you know the old generation we all
kind of celebrate that that time when
when we built and we did things with our
hands
the race of gentlemen is definitely
helping to keep the sport alive with the
new generation
[Music]
you